SPEAKER: When I took
the first call about this case,
which was indicating that
two people may have been shot,
many years ago,
and they had been buried
in their own back garden,
part of my reaction was,
surely that can't have happened,
can it?
♪ (MELLOW MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CAROLINE CRAMPTON:
You know those stories
that you puzzle over,
that you just can't
get out of your head?
Well, this is one of those.
Landscapers is a new four-part
drama from HBO and Sky.
It follows the true story of
Susan and Christopher Edwards,
a soft-spoken couple
with a gruesome secret.
I'm Caroline Crampton,
a longtime fan of crime fiction
and the true stories
that inspire it.
In this five-episode companion
podcast from HBO and Sky,
I'm gonna take you
behind the scenes
of Landscapers.
Together, we'll unpack
how a team of filmmakers
adapted the chilling
true crime story
for the limited series
starring Olivia Colman
and David Thewlis.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ED SINCLAIR:
Rightly, there's a lot of energy
devoted to the victims,
but I think there should be
a lot of energy also devoted
to the thinking
of the perpetrators.
CRAMPTON: That's Ed Sinclair,
the series creator.
While writing Landscapers,
he examined every part
of the case,
from a backyard burial
to an obsession
with film memorabilia,
and he worked with the team
to bring the story to life.
SPEAKER 2: It kind of starts out
as like a one-line pitch,
but the more you put in it,
the more it kind of unravels
into this kind of sprawling,
multifaceted,
incredibly complicated
exploration.
SPEAKER 3: As the actor, there's
always got to be a line you draw
because it isn't a documentary,
and it isn't a recreation.
It's a kind of exploration.
CRAMPTON: For some of the team,
adapting this story wasn't easy.
As they learned about the case,
it seeped in and took over.
SPEAKER 4: I had nightmares
about it
when I first
started researching.
Not because of the horror,
so much of the violence
of what happened,
but just trying to imagine
what it's like
to live with that kind of guilt.
CRAMPTON: We also talked to
the real people behind the case,
the one's who experienced it
first-hand.
For them,
this story isn't a TV drama.
It's their lives.
♪ (MELANCHOLY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 5: I remember
it was a rainy night.
I actually walked
to the police station
from my house.
SPEAKER 6: It was
an absolute media circus,
absolutely packed
to the rafters.
SPEAKER 7:
There's probably something
slightly salacious in it.
SPEAKER 8: I-- I like them.
I don't know how far
I can elaborate on that,
but I do.
SPEAKER: This one
just fascinates me.
It almost became an obsession,
I think.
SPEAKER 9: I- I can't say
I feel sorry for them,
because I don't.
Let's not forget
what they've done here
is murdered
two completely innocent people
and taken them for every single
penny that they've got.
CRAMPTON: Landscapers airs
from December 6th on HBO
and from December 7th on Sky.
The Landscapers podcast
arrives December 6th,
with episodes released weekly.
Get ready to find out
what's really buried
in the ground beneath your feet.
♪ (OPERA MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
SPEAKER 10:
Murder is a tragic event.
In the end, that felt like
the sort of truest thing.
That we can never actually know
the inner workings
of another human being.